- Thank you, thank you
everyone for coming,
and we are very glad to
have Professor Kaan Jittiang
visiting us from Chulalongkorn
University in Thailand.
We were lucky that he
was also coming to the US
for other professional reasons
and that we got him to
stop by in New Haven.
And he's a lecturer
in the International Relations
Department at Chulalongkorn,
and he's a sociologist by training.
So I won't do a long introduction.
He has a PhD from the
University of Wisconsin.
He works on migration, refugees,
things of close interest for all of us.
So I won't do a long introduction
because we'd like to hear from him.
So Professor Jittiang,
please take it away.
- All right, thank you
Mushfiq for the introductions
and then good afternoon everyone.
To those of you in the room
and also those of you
who join live we assume,
I'm honored to have opportunities
to give these lectures
as part of the fall seminar series
of the Yales programs on refugees
and false displacement and
also humanitarian responses.
And I'm particularly grateful to Mushfiq
for the invitations, to
Teresa who is here with us,
to Toran Marcus, Courtney,
and also Arlin who help
with the arrangement
for my visit to Yale campus today.
Before delving into my talk for today,
please allow me to give
two preliminary precautions
which I think are worthwhile
to mention beforehand.
First, English is not my native tongue,
so I may have difficulties
conveying some thoughts concisely
on this challenging subjects,
but I will try my very best.
And additionally I speak very fast,
and often get faster when I get nervous,
so making me known as a
rapper among my students.
So besides, I have xxx from
traveling 13 hours ahead of time
to be here with you.
So these combined reasons
may perhaps held justifying
my reading of this talks for today.
Second, this lecture is based
on one of my working papers,
which I started three years ago,
but I still have not
been able to finish it.
And every time, when I get back
to work on this particular paper,
there will always be a new
additions to my LS thoughts
and also my thinkings, and
then I stop moving forward.
Perhaps it was for these reasons
that I decided to give a talk
based on this working paper,
hoping that I will be able
to finish it eventually.
And I'm not saying this
to actually manage or to
diminish your expectations,
but I mentioned this in the
hope of garnering your thoughts
and feedback for me to
improve this particular paper.
For those of you who may not be familiar
with Bangkok at Thailand and
the refugee situations there,
please allow me to provide some context
and factual information about the cities
and countries which can
help lay foundations
for my lectures today.
First, Thailand is a country
located in south Asia
with Bangkok being its capital.
Thailand has approximately
70 million people,
around 15% of whom or around
10.5 million live in Bangkok.
And if we include in adjacent provinces
which form the Bangkok metropolitan areas,
the entire population will increase
to approximately 15 to 16 million people.
Second among millions of people
living in the Bangkok metropolitan areas,
are thousands of urban refugees
from at least 44 countries.
The official data from the
UNHCR office in Bangkok
suggests that there are
five thousands of them.
However, based on the
observations of both CSO
and also my own research team,
we think that the actual
number of refugees
should be between 5,000 and 20,000 people.
The major countries of origins
for urban refugees in Bangkok,
including Pakistan, Vietnam,
Somalia, Afghanistan,
Iraq, Sri Lanka, and also Palestine.
These groups of urban
refugees that I will discuss
are just these groups of people.
My talk will not include the
new arrivals from Myanmar,
whose situation is more
complicated and complex,
but please feel free to ask
questions related to them
during the Q&A later.
Third, Thailand is one of those countries
in south and southeast Asia,
which are non-signatory states
during 1951 conventions
relating to the status of
refugees and its 1967 protocol.
However, it has a long
history of refugee management.
Thailand also allows UNHCR
to conduct refugees status
determination of ISD,
but the irony is that the Thai government
does not recognize the UNHCR
court or the refugee status.
And just before the
COVID-19 pandemic started,
Thailand enacted the first refugee law
to determine the status
of those who generally need protections.
The mechanisms has become known
as the national screening
mechanisms or NSM.
The mechanism has not yet been enforced
since the eligibility criteria
that I was part of drafting committee
just got approved by
the cabinet last week.
The fact that Thailand
is a non-signatory state
and the NSM is not yet operating,
refugees continue to be illegal migrants.
The terms that the Thai
Immigration Bureau use
to refer to these groups of people.
Officially refugees are subjected
to arrests and detention,
and just on the day I arrived in the US,
12 of them from the Khmer
Krom community were arrested
and detained in the
Immigration Detention Center.
Thus, as several scholars
of refugees in Thailand
have criticized and illustrated,
it is not an situation to say
that urban refugees in Bangkok
continue to live in fear
and also in a very hostile environment.
My lectures today will
highlight apparel situations
in which refugee asylums in Bangkok
continues to be possible,
despite what I describe as fear
or hostile environment just now.
More importantly,
urban refugees continue
to arrive in Bangkok
regardless of the
difficulties they may face
or endure in the cities.
And let me start my lectures
today with some anecdotes.
Here's how the story begins.
So while conducting field work
in Bangkok in December, 2018,
I had an opportunity to meet
Junior among refugees team
to a local lawyer
at the church near Don
Mueang International Airport.
At the time of our encounters,
the lawyer did not inform
me who Junior really was,
apart from saying that he
was a community volunteer.
As teenagers walked toward us,
Junior greeted me with a why?
Xxx gestures and
introduced himself in Thai.
Junior greeted me and say, Thai.
His Thai was flawless.
And I could not help thinking
that he was a local xxx staff
working for the lawyers office.
Only after our conversation
a few minutes later,
I realized I was wrong.
Junior is a refugees
registered with UNHCR,
who has come to live in
Thailand since he was a boy
together with his family of six.
He was the second child
of the Hmong pastor.
He fled to Thailand
due to religious persecution
in northern Vietnam.
His Thai was flawless
because he did go to
the Thai primary school
before quitting to help
earn income for his family.
Junior also speaks Thai with his siblings
and friends in the same
community and at home.
However, Junior has continued
to be able to speak his
native tongue, Hmong,
he also learned English at a church
and his father's encouraging
him to study Chinese.
His language skills landed
him a job as a translator
for various refugee organizations
where he continued to work all the days.
Since our first encounter,
I have become a frequent
visitors to Junior's family
and his community.
I participated in some
of their activities.
I learned several remarkable
insights from their experiences
and livelihoods in Bangkok.
And let me mention to you,
Junior's father, the pastor,
is at the core of the public community.
He's not only a spiritual guide,
but also a community
leader who plays a role
in structuring the xxx community.
At the end of Sunday mass,
he often took the opportunity
to foster community spirit and unity.
In the absence of justice in Thailand
due to their lack of legal status.
In the absence of access to
justice xxx, my apologies,
the pastor and some key community members
serve as the elders who
adjudicate community conflicts
and familiar disputes.
The elders also play an essential role
in bringing employment
opportunities to community members.
They leverage their social network
primarily to the Hmong people
who have already been living
in Thailand for decades,
and from the previous employers
to get people to work.
Not everyone is employed.
Although they can get
jobs, I must note that
these jobs are available
in the informal sectors
with no legal contracts.
These includes a translation
job that Junior has as well.
The home of the pastors and the church
serve as a community centers
where community activities occur.
Before the COVID-19 pandemic,
while adults and teens
would go to mass on Sunday,
the second floor of the home of the pastor
would turn into nurseries
where volunteers would
come and teach English
to young kids.
The first floor of the house
also serve as a community workshop
where ladies would go and
engage in making handcrafts
and products like this.
Some of these are sold through
the CHAMALiiN projects,
established by local refugee organizations
to empower female refugees.
Despite opportunities,
the Hmong communities also face challenges
because of they say illegally in Thailand.
Rates and arrests still
affect community members.
However, in many instance,
Thai neighbors help shield them
by providing informations
about police monitoring
in the area,
so they will not be subjected
to arrest and detentions.
During the COVID-19 pandemic,
the informal structures of the community
also play a vital role
in spreading informations
about COVID-19 interventions
and helping manage those getting infected.
And this is the pictures
from the mass at the church
that they gathered every Sunday.
Some part of the stories,
such as the existence
of the community elders
may be unique to the Hmong community.
However, based on interviews
that my team and I conducted,
the refugees from 10
nationalities in 10 communities,
the overall experiences of
refugees are strikingly similar,
ranging from the stories of
their journeys into Thailand,
people overstaying their visa,
and get to stay in Thailand more longer
to the stories of
pathway to get employment
and their experience of urban institution.
The story I just told you
may also resonate with
urban refugee experiences
in other countries as well.
If these stories are so common,
why do I still mention them?
I mention them because these stories
bring me to the key
puzzles for my talk today.
How is refugee asylums
in Thailand possible
despite the hostile legal environments?
How could we explain these phenomenon?
There are various factors of course.
Elsewhere, I did explain the
role of the social network,
the importance of the
Thai government policies
and the existence of refugee
organizations and UNHCR office.
But what about the space where
they live, like the city?
How does the city shape and
make refugee asylums possible?
How should we understand the connection
between the cities and refugees,
especially their abilities
to navigate livelihoods
in the cities without
legal status and rights?
Personally, I think refugee scholars
have taken the connections
between the cities and refugees
for granted and too likely.
They focus excessively on
the relative advantages
that the cities bring to refugees
compared to those in camp,
such as free mobilities,
employment opportunities.
I do not deny these explanations,
but I believe that we can better theorize
the refugees cities nexus
and this is what exactly
I'm trying to accomplish
by the end of of this talk today.
Therefore, I am trying
to bring urban studies
to contribute to refugee
studies in my talk,
to explain how refugees
constructed asylums
in non-signatory states.
My argument is as follow, "The
city's three forms of powers,
"including environmental,
discursive and material powers,
"have bolstered the resilience of refugees
"by providing them with
three essential capacities
"for city navigations.
"And through which it's allowed
"the refugees to be able
to construct asylums
"even in the context of a
non-signatory states by Thailand."
I do now introduce two
interrelated concept,
which is central to my
arguments and my explanations,
urban power and refugee resilience.
Urban power.
For those of you who study urban
politics and urban studies,
the xxx.
For decades, we have seen the
emergence of other discussions
about urban power.
For example, in the
famous book "Who Governs,"
by Robert Dahl who taught here at Yale,
and brought about the cities of New Haven,
also led us to understand
urban powered structure.
From there, we also seen
the growing literatures
on urban power relations,
power in the cities,
or even "Cities of Power,"
which is the title of a book
by Therborne, that just
came out couple years ago.
Power in the Cities continue
to be a recurring theme
in urban affairs nowadays,
although some have moved on
to talk about urban
governance, for example.
On the other hand,
urban power is also
discussed among sociologists
and geographer who have
looked into urban powers
from a slightly different perspective.
This seem to focus more on
the power of place and space,
and the power of the cities.
And how these shape social
relations and interactions.
We often hear them proclaim xxx matters.
We have seen the classic
sociological work of Sampson,
on "Neighborhood effects,"
which attempts to explain
how the neighborhoods can
be an essential determinant
of socioeconomic stratifications.
For me, urban power relations
as well as social interactions
are quite crucial for
the construction of life
and of the cities.
I look into the world of a
geographer like Robert Sack,
who argue that the
power of place and space
comes only from the xxx rules
about what is in and our place.
But again, who make those rules.
It is those who govern that place
and perhaps those who comes
from social interactions
that give meaning to such a place.
For this reason,
these multiple social,
political, and economic relations
eventually lend power to the city.
It was from this urban power
that new arrivals, for example,
migrants or refugees could
derive their resilience
and integrate into the cities.
Because there are multiple
forms of relations
and governance in the cities,
there can be various form of urban power.
Today my talks will focus
on only three forms,
environmental, discursive
and material powers.
Other urban powers can be
elusive and so abstracts.
I believe it would be
worthwhile to defy it
as a form of power embedded in the cities
emerging from complex relations
that shape the dynamics of the cities
and the city constructions.
Second, the term refugee resilience.
From a rather traditional concepts,
that I introduced just now,
I would like to move on
to discuss a more
fashionable term resilience,
which has been used
widely in various fields.
Generally the terms refer
to positive adaptations
and capabilities to
recover from challenges
and setbacks quickly.
Some scholars even treat
resilience as a paradigm.
In refugee studies, resilience
is also very popular,
especially among those
studying refugee wellbeing
and those focusing on livelihood
adjustment and strategies.
My usage of the term is
also pretty straightforward.
I adopt these terms because
I see it as more encompassing.
For me, it is suitable,
because when we talk about resilience
we can look into two
interconnected components
of capacities.
The first is to have capacities
and the second is connected
to the abilities to use such capacities
to make difference in the situations,
and life situations in particular.
With the concept of resilience,
it is also important to note,
that we can give agency
back to refugee themselves,
as many states often
take that away from them
and put them into a positions
a burden or dependence.
In conceptualizing resilience,
most literatures would focus more
on resilience that come from within,
meaning to look into their
mental adjustment in itself
and available resources
and social network.
But for me, when we
think about resilience,
or refugees resilience in particular,
especially in the context
of urban refugees,
resilience also come from the city itself.
Different forms of urban power
provide various capacities
and in my talk you will see,
which I'm gonna show you
later on in the table.
From which thoughts these
resilience are coming from.
Different form of urban power
provide various capacities.
And to repeat my arguments
again, the CD3 forms,
which including material, discursive,
and environmental powers,
they have bolsters,
materials, discursive, and
environmental capacities.
Now that I have laid foundations
for my conceptual framework
for the subject matters,
please allow me to delve into
details for each one of them
and then also to provide you
with some empirical evidence.
The empirical evidence
which provide insights
into what I'm presenting today
is come from ethnographic field work
that have been conducted in Thailand
for the past three years,
observing communities
activities and engage with them,
having conversations with
those ends of local CSOs
and also more than 140 interviews
that my team and I conducted
with refugees back in 2020s.
These interviews were
conducted as part of attempts
to understand refugee
integration in Thailand,
and it was conducted via telephone.
We adopt this method since at that time
it was the beginning of the pandemic,
and we were not able to
get into the community.
They were conducted over
the period of four months
between Septembers and December 2020s,
and a team of five
people, including myself,
we engaged in this interview all together.
Now going into detail
for each one of them,
these are the form of urban
powers I'm talking about
and the form of resilience
that correspond with
different urban powers.
I will start first with the
first form of urban power,
which is the urban environmental powers,
which is corresponding with
the environmental capacities.
When hearing the term
environmental powers,
people often go back to the the work
and the thinking of Thorstein Veblen,
who argue in the Theory
of the Leisure Class
that environmental power emerge
from how people demonstrate
their command of the environment
to their wealth and social positions.
Environmental power
therefore would become an
indicator of social power.
Based on Veblen's insights,
these advantages, people,
may also have environmental power
if we think of this in the relative terms,
but that power would be
lesses to the wealthier
and those with higher social positions.
However, the critical
questions we also have to ask,
it's where is environmental
powers comes from?
Well, you need access
to the environment first
to be able to command it.
If that's the case,
then this environmental
power is not simply related,
but come from human interactions
with the environment
to amend or chain the landscapes,
build new structures through
the social interactions
that human has with the environment.
It is unsurprising
that powers has also led to
the restructures environment.
Also giving the environment
the so-called power
as well in turn, which can
then be learned to anyone,
including those with
less power than refugees.
Let me put this in more concrete
terms of urban refugees.
When I'm talking about the
environment in this context,
I'm talking mainly about
the built environment.
This is all the physical
parts of where we live, rest,
work and perform or engage
in various activities
in a city such as Bangkok.
The built environment is complex.
Buildings become a fortress
where people can shoot
themselves from one another.
These form a social
interactions between humans
and the built environment,
made the environmental power
of the city very powerful.
Authority cannot penetrate all areas
unless there are reports
from those living in
those built environment.
People can become invisible
behind the concrete balls
in their private apartment.
These former urban powers
therefore left refugees
the environmental capacities
to make a decision
to command how they will
use the built environment
to xxx, or enhance other
social and economic benefits.
Usually they will prioritize safety, why?
As I mentioned before,
refugees are considered
illegal migrants in Thailand.
They can be arrested and detained.
For example, one Palestinian family I visited,
will close their house
door most of the time,
whether they're inside or not.
Sabiha always said to me,
"We always feel safer here in this house
"when we close the door."
But actually the side of the house itself
is also a very safe place
because it's located in
the gated communities
of most Thai people.
But being in a commodity environment
made refugees feel a double
layers of cell protections.
The housing choice
is also related to their access to a xxx
and also job sites.
However, is essential to note that
when a number of refugees
moving into community
and other areas together,
the city environmental powers
may hinder the refugees
environmental capacities as well.
There were several incidents
of refugees getting arrested
because of the neighborhood
reported a high concentrations
of foreigners or refugees
living in the areas
to local police.
The second form of urban power
that I will be discussing
is discursive power.
This form of urban powers emerged
from the city's densities,
varieties, and diversities
of people, places and space.
The city has posted this power
perhaps since the city start to expand.
We can trace back to the work
of Wirth on Urbanisms in 1938,
where he talks about
the heterogeneity of people in the cities
and the later works of
other urban sociologists.
We have discussed
anonymities in the cities.
What does it mean to the
capacity of the people?
The city provide capacities for refugees
to move in and out xxx
depending on place and space.
In the context of this discursive powers,
particularly in the context of Thailand,
I'm talking about the
new categories of people
label as refugee migrants.
Because of Thailand is a non-xxx state,
as I mentioned before, and always,
refugees are not recognized as refugees.
Even those with UNHCR cards,
they are known as a person
of concerns to UNHCR
and they prefer to identify
themselves as migrants,
especially to the locals
who are potential employers.
The urban discursive powers
therefore allow refugees to xxx and xxx
their own stories,
making them in command of their labels.
This is precisely what
xxx say that refugees,
"Have a very context dependence
"and pragmatic relationship
to their labels."
In extreme cases, that's
what I mentioned already.
In extreme cases, urban discursive powers
also allows some refugees to pass as Thai.
Passing refers to the process
by which an individual can cross over
from one identity to another
based on specific attributes.
In the case of urban refugees in Thailand,
that is the Thai language, xxx,
combined with a similar
physical appearance.
Passing is a forceful form
of discursive capacities,
that urban refugee used
to avoid getting arrests
if police encountered them on the street
or at the construction site.
The Hmong refugees for example,
mentioned to be in quote,
"We look like Thai people
and speak the language well,
"so we can get away with
many things in Thailand."
Last but not least, material powers,
which does not need much explanations.
This is perhaps the most
widely discussed connections
between refugees and the cities.
The urban material powers
emerge from the economic
relations in the cities.
We have seen multiple
economics areas of the cities,
either it being the site productions
or the locus xxx.
Economic relation helps
structures urban material powers.
This power in turn
structures social relations
between economic agents, namely employers,
and also employees.
What the city use to urban refugees
in the case of Thailand is
capacities in the economic realm
or material capacities,
which allows them to navigate employment
and jobs opportunities and
acquire material needs.
Bank of Thailand approximates
that size of the high informal
economies between 45 to 50%,
and has xxx more than 60%
of the workforce in the countries.
Bangkok as the country capitals,
and economic and financial
center of the countries,
also serve as a major hub
for the informal sectors.
Our interviews review
that Bangkok has provided
various economic
opportunities for refugees.
The extent to which they
could acquire those chances
also varies depending on
their skill, experiences,
network and connections.
But let me show you
some datas that we filed
from 140 interview that we did.
74% of the 140 respondents
were engaged in income
gathering activities
in the informal sectors
before the pandemic.
20% of all the respondents who
reported working in Thailand
had worked in at least two jobs.
And respondent wages varies.
Some wages could be as low as $1 per day
for picking dry chili tips
to others receiving up to 800
or around 20 US dollars per
day working in organizations,
depending on their skills required.
Those low wages perhaps explain
why they are working in multiple jobs.
These datas that are
presented to you here,
show not only what a city
like Bangkok can provide
for urban refugees,
but also the extent urban
refugees have already contributed
with their material
capacities to the Thai economy
and the cities, how the city
urban power enabled them
to have these particular capacities.
However, the contributions
of urban refugees in Bangkok
xxx.
Up to this point,
I have already provided
a detailed explanations
of the interactions
between urban powers
and refugee resilience,
focusing on three forms
of capacities as xxx.
And these urban powers
and the corresponding forms
of refugee capacities,
which I frame them as
a refugees resilience
help make asylum possible
for urban refugees,
even in the context of a
non-signatory states like Thailand.
Auto-focusing on both factors,
I just want to repeat it again
that I recognize the significance
of some other factors
that I mentioned at the
beginning of my talk.
Before I end this talk,
I would like to address one final issues
regarding the sustainabilities of asylums.
Auto city like Bangkok can
provide xxx for refugees.
The fact that refugees
can settle their asylums
with urban powers and resilience
has also become a barriers
for their onward movement
and limbo as a refugees.
Let me now revisit the stories
of the Hmong communities
that I started.
In June 2019, I visited
Junior's family as usual,
and this time I had chance
to discuss with his father,
pastor, for almost two hours.
He told me that his families
face resettlement challenges.
A sponsor in Canada told the pastor
that he wants to sponsor someone
else who is really in need
since the pastor's family seems
to be better off in Bangkok.
The pastor told me with low voice,
"I was quite surprised
that he said that to me.
"We are indeed better off
economically in Bangkok,
"but that is what we must do to survive.
"It also doesn't mean we
won't need protections.
"The Thai government didn't
recognize our status."
Because of the resettlement uncertainties,
the pastor's currently
exploring other options
for his families.
One of them was to have
Junior or another of his sons
get resettled first either
in Canada or somewhere else.
He's also preparing for the worse
if the families and the communities
must continue living in
Thailand for years to come.
And he saying, "God, (indistinct)."
Being able to seek asylum is one thing,
but moving to a third country is another,
and the latters continue to be the hope
of nearly all urban refugees in Thailand,
despite knowing that the chance
has become increasingly limited.
As Thailand will soon launch
its own national screening mechanisms,
providing urban refugees
with temporary legal status
while seeking asylums in Thailand.
Is also the time to see
whether urban refugees
will chain their perceptions
regarding asylum seeking in Bangkok.
In fact, many do not merely
seek asylums in the cities,
but have already integrated
into the Thai society
in some way.
Whether it is asylums or integrations,
I believe that urban
power and refugee asylum
are part of the ingredients
making the livelihoods
of these urban refugees
continue to be a path of survival.
I want to end my talk with
some key implications.
First, cities may be another factors
contributing to refugee asylums,
but it is indeed the essential one.
Second, urban power
play a significant part
in empowering refugee agencies
and also enabling their asylums.
Empowering refugees therefore,
require the empowerment of the cities
and also the urban power.
And finally, although constructing asylums
in a non-signatory states
may be challenging,
the case of urban refugees in Thailand
that I show in my talk today
indicates that it's possible.
In fact, the possibility of asylum
in some non-signatory states
can be far greater than that
in the signatory states.
That's the end of my talk.
Thank you so much.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you so much for
such a wonderful talk.
I am gonna serve as a bit of a moderator,
so if you have questions,
maybe you can raise your hand
and I think we have plenty of time.
So, we can take each one one by one
and you can go out and answer
and then if we sort of run
out of things to discuss,
I have some questions in mind as well.
But I'll love for you all
to ask your questions first,
if anyone wants to start?
Well, I'm happy to like
use my, I guess my power,
as discussing to ask a
question that I have.
- Yes.
- And then maybe that'll let
everyone gather their thoughts.
So, I guess just to
sort of plough the field
and make sure we're using the same terms,
I'd love to hear you
talk a little bit about
why you as a researcher,
as a kind of doing the
political work you do,
why you choose to call
these individuals refugees,
not migrants and not asilis,
and why you don't adopt the term
that the government
uses of refugee-migrant,
refugee migrant.
- All right.
- And related to that,
I'm personally curious
about the idea
that the urban refugees are
seeking a space of asylum.
How does that differentiate from an asyli?
Do you use those terms
interchangeably or yeah,
just a little bit more information
on how you conceptualize
these different categories.
- Right.
- It's also fine if they're
like not meaningful for you
because of your work,
but yeah, just so we're.
- Yeah, I think it's really
important to actually go back
and think about those terms as well.
Because the way I use the
term it's quite different
from some of concepts that
been discussing elsewhere.
So when I use the term
refugees, it depends,
and it's actually based
on the cell identification
of the refugees themselves.
So that's how I...
Because for example, this talk,
even though I talk about
urban power, right?
How I constructed or focus on
the three form of urban powers
actually come from the data that I got
from refugees themselves.
So if they identify
themselves as refugees,
of course I take it as refugees.
I will give you some example.
For example, in the case
of the more community,
there are a lot of people who
are known as a closed case.
These closed case are the people
who used to go through the
process of seeking asylums,
you know, go through the
ISD process with UNHCR,
and then that case got closed, right?
But the fact that that case got closed
doesn't mean that they are not refugees.
It means that because of perhaps
they don't have enough
documents or evidence
to actually prove at that time being,
and they can go through
the process again, right?
So because of this,
I feel like it wouldn't do justice to them
if they identify it
elsewhere in some other ways,
you know, like for example,
or in the way that Thai government
would identify refugees.
So in the case of Thailand,
refugees actually known in multiple ways.
Like for example,
the early groups of refugees
that came into Thailand,
they were known as the
displays, Vietnamese displays,
and so on and so forth.
The more recent group from Myanmar, right?
Also known as people fleeing, fighting.
That was the first time,
the first group that came
in 1980s and nineties.
And then recent groups,
it's known that people fleeing
and so for example, right?
So it's a whole bunch of category,
but then at the end of the day,
I feel like all this term is
just related to the policies
that governing them, but
it doesn't do justice
to the actual identities
of refugee themselves.
That's the first thing.
Second thing, when I use the term
refugees migrants though, right?
That was the time that I also recognize
that if refugees want to
define themselves differently
when they're talking
about different contexts,
for example, in the context
of employment, right?
In that case, I also use
the term migrant as well.
So the way I describe it really depends
on how they actually
use the terms basically.
And for the term asylums,
the second questions,
I haven't thought about that much yet,
but I often use it in the
condition with some other terms,
and other terms I use
often as well with refuge.
But then in these presentations,
because I feel like the
term refuge, it means that,
it gives a sense of how
there will be some structures
that governing them in
some way still, right?
And to a large degree it's
related to the UNHCR structures,
but in the term asylums that I chose here,
it's more like how it comes
from the way that refugees
themselves can draw
on their capacities to build it.
So that's why I prefer this term more
in presenting this today.
Hopefully I answered both questions.
- [Teresa] Yes, you did.
Thank you very much.
- Yes.
- [Teresa] Thank you for this talk.
It was really interesting.
I guess I have two sort of
very different questions.
The first is why Thailand has not signed
onto the 1951 convention
and what discussion is
taking place around that
in the government.
And then the second one is,
just wondering about the
way that you use resilience,
and if you're engaging
with critical like, criticism
of that term, right?
Because a lot of folks,
particularly advocates
of marginalized people
have talked about the way that
resilience focuses on people
and on their behavior
instead of on structures
that are constraining them
or producing vulnerability, right?
And so I wonder how you
kinda reconcile that.
- Okay, let me start from
the the first question,
why Thailand is not
signing the conventions.
I have traces about the
history of refugee management
in Thailand, and actually
it's about politics
of how Thailand sees its
positions way back in 1950.
So in 1950, actually the
early groups of refugees
that came to Thailand
are the KMT soldiers.
They came from China during that time,
and a lot of them were setups there.
But at the same time,
during that period of time,
there was also a dispute in the ICJ
regarding one of the
third trees of Thailand
that related to Cambodia.
I think this is part of the reasons
why in the calculations of
Thai government at that time,
that first, they don't want
to hold responsibilities
of taking care of refugees.
That's the first thing.
But second thing is that
because of they afraid of the
dividing of the obligations
that were related to the case
at the ICJ at that time also.
That was the historical reasons.
But then in a modern periods,
there have been four times that
there was research conducted
on shoot Thailand, you
know, sign the conventions.
And all the research that came out
say that Thailand should
not sign the convention
and they're gonna do the
fifth one very soon actually,
whether or not they're
gonna sign the conventions.
But the arguments right now is that
because of the content in the conventions
are no longer related to
the real world situations,
it's not up to date basically, right?
And Thailand always have one argument,
which I think that also resonates
with some other countries
that we do more already
than the signatory states.
Why should we do the conventions?
For example, one of the example
that Thailand will use likely
in this December refugee forum
is that, we already, you know,
creating the national
screening mechanisms,
and these mechanisms
could be a replacement
of the conventions, right?
So that's the kind of
thing that Thailand feel
that if the refugee
conventions get updated,
and then we also have
some other thing else
that we already doing, so then that...
Unless that updated version is there,
then we would sign the conventions.
Otherwise it would not agree
to sign the conventions
I believe, and they don't
see the importance of it also
in terms of that.
Nevertheless saying that doesn't mean
that Thailand does not really oblige
to international you know,
responsibilities at all
because there are some other instruments
that make Thailand taking
care of refugees also.
And what's more important,
and also is that if you look into the text
of the national screening
mechanisms, which I mentioned,
the definitions of our persecutions
and also the definition of
refugees, it's expanding,
it goes beyond the definitions
in the conventions.
So in that case, it's quite
progressive in a sense,
but then we have to see whether
in the interpretation of it,
will it retains that
progressiveness or not.
So that's to answer the questions
on the design of the conventions.
The term resilience, yeah,
I mean I think that's really interesting
the way you ask the questions
because I have to admit
that I did not engage much
with the critical side of that yet,
and then I try to go along
with the mainstream in itself.
But when I think about the
resilience here, as I mentioned,
it's also related to the
capacities of them in itself,
and it's the lending from the structures
that resilience emerge, right?
So I'm not talking about resilience
of the structure in itself,
but I'm talking about how the
power within the structure,
like urban power is the one
that lend this resilience
to the capacity.
So at the end of the day
still focus on the people themselves,
and how they'd be able
to have that capacities.
But then when I'm talking
about the capacities here,
the reason why I decided
to use the term resilience,
at first when I started off this paper,
I didn't use the term resilience,
I using the term capacities.
But then one of my colleagues
criticize that usage
in the way that when you
think about capacities alone,
you are assuming that they just have it,
but you're not talking
about how they actually
be able to spring back.
But in the case of refugees, you know,
it's not just having capacities,
but they use these capacities
to make something else
happening for them,
and that means liveing
possibilities and so on.
So in this case, that's why
I go to the term resilience,
and I go with the term
resilience, for that reason,
to also extend the part of capacities
from not just having capacities,
but to focus on how
they use the capacities
to construct the resilience, basically.
- [Teresa] There is a question
from somebody on Zoom,
and I'll read that.
If urban power,
especially the built environment
and environmental power
is considered to be a central component
of refugee resilience in a city
with such host hostile environment,
to what extent do development
project like string cleanups
and other physical changes to
the city affect this power?
Are there any pathway for
refugees or their advocates
to be a part of city
planning at this point?
- Okay, I think this really
depends on the context.
Now, this is where the
context gonna matters a lot.
In the case of Bangkok right now,
I think that refugees are being part
of the construction of the cities
because one of the key jobs
that several refugee groups are engaging,
is actually the
construction of the cities,
the construction work and so on.
And if you look into the survey,
I mean in other public of
my, on their human capitals,
it shows that most of them
identify construction
as being their own skill
that they already have.
So in that sense you know,
in terms of being engaged
in the construction of the cities
in a way of the create,
the creation of the build
environment, they were part of it.
But now in terms of the city planning,
this is another question,
that refugees at least in
the context of Thailand,
they're not able to do so yet.
And the reason why, because
of course, you know,
the lack of legal status.
And because of the lack of legal state,
it means that they are not,
they are also afraid of
even going out to be exposed
or to be visible most of the time.
And because of the fear of
being visible in that sense,
it leads them to taking
part in terms of plannings
or engaging in policies.
Second thing, not all groups of refugees
engage or speak Thai language, right?
Only certain groups of them
that really do speak Thai.
And because of this, it
also part of the reasons
why refugees were not you
know, be really engaged
in that kind of planning and so on.
And most of them still dream
of transit through Thailand,
the transit words, the terms
that in the (indistinct)
it's got constructed to
different factors and so on.
But also in the imagination
of refugees themselves
that they want to transit through Thailand
and go somewhere else.
And because of the thinking
about transitting to Thailand
and to go somewhere else,
it made them less engaged
politically or internal planning
or the cities and so on and so forth.
Nevertheless, because of
the resettlement opportunity
become limited, nowadays
several refugee organizations
within the countries,
particularly local CSO
engaged more in empowering refugees
so that they can be part
of these city planning.
But I mean, in some other cases,
perhaps I think it may be viable,
but in the case of context
of Bangkok at the moment,
I don't think that it's
the case yet, yeah.
- [Teresa] And then a follow up from that,
are children for example,
allowed to go to school?
So what happens to the
next generation, basically?
- Right.
- [Teresa] Do they consider
or view themselves?
- This is the most important question.
So, one thing is that refugees
in Thailand can go to school.
All students can go to Thai school.
And it's guarantee in the constitutions
that all kids in the country,
regardless of what race,
ethnic cities they are,
they can go to school.
But then when you go to school,
the school also teach everything
in the Thai language, right?
So that's part of the reason
why some of them do not go to Thai school,
and then because of some of
them want to just make a transit
and not make a living in Bangkok.
So they decided not to send
their kids to the school.
That's the decision
the refugee themselves.
Second things was that it's
also about the structures.
When refugees going to the Thai school,
what happened is that
sometimes the principals
may make decisions
not to admit them into school,
or even if they're already in a school,
they not allow or encourage
them to continue their studies
in a higher level by not
giving them, for example,
the certificate, right?
So it's a challenge.
It's not simply just in terms of you know,
the access is already there,
but how the manuring behind it,
it's become something
that borrowed access.
And at the same time
for them to actually climb up the ladders
and become successful within
the context of Thailand,
it also limits it because
of that structure in itself.
Nevertheless, when one
good news that is coming in
from the case of Thailand
is that if you look into the convention
on the Rio of children,
Thailand is the last country in the world
to reserve articles of
22nd, which is focused
specifically on the rise
of the refugee shooting.
So this year, it's a year
that Thailand is trying
to you know, withdraw
from that particular articles,
and I have opportunities
to be able to take part
in that process as well.
So they are laying the power
to plan for the withdrawal
from the CRC Article 22.
So that should provide
a pathway for childrens
and to integrate more into Thailand
and to get more support for them, yeah.
Yes, Marcus.
- [Marcus] Yeah, so I have two questions.
One is about,
I was really struck by your
use of like environment,
particularly like speaking
about the urban environment
because like from the perspective,
environmental history,
it's quite separate from urban history
where urban is not considered
as part of the environment.
So I'm just wondering like
how does nature figure
in the kind of research that you do,
especially thinking about
questions of refugee narratives
of landscape, memory and
place, like place making.
Because they are the space,
they probably come from a
kind of different landscape
than the bank of urban environment.
Like how does that change their experience
or how do they negotiate with that?
The second question that I have is,
how does this research
like relate to like current
studies of globalization
and refugees?
I'm thinking specifically about
like the work of Aron Matthews
and about like (indistinct) mentions
the ghetto of the end of the
world, the center of the world,
where you know, that in
that particular example,
Hong Kong is both aspirational
for the kind of middle class
in developing countries,
but also they're marginalized, right?
Within Hong Kong society.
So is there a kind of similar dynamic
that's played out in your
research that you observe?
- All right, thank you so much Marcus.
So let me start from the first questions.
To think about the
change of the experience.
Actually, one thing that
I find is so interesting
was that because of, as I
mentioned in the stories,
at the beginning of the
Hmong community, right?
Once they move to Thailand
and the lack of legal status,
lack of access to justice, for example,
what would be the alternative?
Then that is the time
when they adopt, you know,
like the structure, social
structures that they had already
in their home countries or into Thailand.
So it's kind of the
reputations of that structure
is that already at play there.
But at the same time,
they also try to match it
with the context that
is already different.
Okay, that's the second part
of the first questions that I answer.
The thing that I think about
environment, I think that
you know, when you
think about environment,
there are multiple dimensions
to environment, right?
When we hear about the word environment,
of course, we think about
a forest, nature and so on.
But if you think about
the second dimensions
or the second phase of the environment,
it's something around us here.
It could be rhetorical in a sense, right?
Or if we think about
the third environment,
it could be something that
got described somewhere
and so on.
So there are multiple ways
or multiple dimensions
to the terms environment itself.
And the way I use it's to focus it more
based on not just the nature,
but the amending of the nature
in the way that allows everything else
to be built on that nature.
So nature may be there as a
ground and so on and so forth,
but on on top of that,
it got those built environment
that become part of my explanations.
So I hope that I answer
most of the first question,
both parts of the first question.
The second question is
internal marginalization, yes.
The answer is yes,
that they got marginalized
within the cities
and most of the time many of
them will push into poverty.
So if you see, I did not show you the data
that I gathered from the interview.
The 140 interviews that I did.
It was the case that most
of the refugees themselves
after COVID 19 hits really hard,
they will push out of the jobs
so they no longer have it at all.
Like even some of the home
base and workshops so on.
And they become more
dependent than ever on it.
Nevertheless, it's not all
the communities are the same.
Some communities that
have a strong structure
that they imported from the home countries
for example, in the Hmong community,
their resilience was still
going strong and very well,
they can spring back
pretty quickly, right?
So in that case, I think the
degree to marginalizations,
it depends on the degrees
in which they integrate into the societies
and how they expand the network
based on that integrations.
So it's come down to that questions.
And then I think that
we cannot say that, oh,
our group of urban
refugees are (indistinct).
I mean there are groups that
are really, really marginalized
comparing to the other.
So it's a matter of degrees,
I think to a large extent.
- [Teresa] We have now
a question from Ardlin.
- [Ardlin] Hi, thank you
so much for your talk.
I wish I was there.
So just to follow up on this,
I had a couple questions.
So the first was this question
about integration, right?
So between Thai and Hmong people.
I'm wondering how do they
negotiate the identity?
You mentioned that they were
able to speak for a good Thai,
Hmong and different languages.
I'm wondering to what extent
do they navigate this identity issue
in a sense of like, do they
believe in like Buddhist,
like Thai customs or practices?
Do they bring in their Hmong
kind of practices as well?
To what extent do they conceive of nature
in a way that Thai people
would versus Hmong people?
Because for example, when I
was talking to Hmong people
in northern Thailand,
they had very different
conceptions of like causality
for like natural disasters
and how to then address that.
And for example, talking Tanghang
the different animistic ways
of dealing with understanding the world.
I'm just curious to what
extent they integrate
you know, in their kind of metaphysical
as well as kind of like
identity practices and language.
Sorry, the second
question was about power.
And in Thai studies there's
just kind of like tension
between (indistinct) and I'm not, right?
This idea about kind of like moral power
versus like an authority over something.
Does that figure into this form of power
or is it more a different form
of power like (indistinct)
or a capability that you're
seeing as an empowering term?
I'm just wondering how this term of power
relates between the languages.
I don't speak Hmong, but maybe something
that they might be thinking about as well.
And sorry, the last
question is about networks.
So you mentioned in the
material power section
and the informal economy,
that opportunities
depends on network skills
and connections.
And I think this is a
very interesting parallel
with Hindris paper.
She did a journal article in Quran,
and she talked about amid
their legal precarity,
they have the sense of resilience
through their networks, right?
So I'm wondering for these Hmong people,
what are their networks like?
What is a good network,
what is not a good network?
How are they bringing in
their social structures or not
and what that looks like.
Thank you.
- All right, thank you so much Al.
Because of the questions,
focus more on the Hmong
community and then as my talk,
like feature both this
particular community,
both at the beginning and at the end.
So I will first have to mention this
about the network itself.
The network is the most important
parts of their resilience.
I mean, particularly
for the Hmong community,
because of these networks, because of it,
it comes not simply just because
they're already in Bangkok,
but it started actually
over a long period of time.
That even before they move into Thailand,
they already known some of the people,
you know, within the Hmong community
and then they already have a separated
groups of the Hmong communities,
like across Thailand, Thais, and Vietnam,
and they know among itself, right?
So this network was fostered
not just simply because
of they move into Thailand
and they found that network,
but then they known about this
network for quite sometime.
And perhaps this is part of
the reasons why they integrated
into Thailand for that reason.
Also come to Thailand for that reason.
The second thing that I
really have to mention
about the network that they have
is that if you look or you're keen
into the employment opportunities
that they be able to gather,
particularly for the Hmong community,
it's actually also in the historic areas
where the Hmong people used to stay,
including the Lao Hmong
that came into Thailand,
and for example in areas
near (indistinct) province
and so on and so forth.
So that's, for example,
once they have no job
opportunities in Bangkok,
some of the people would
go and do those areas
in order to get the
opportunities and so on so forth.
In terms of the identity itself,
I don't think that I can
comment more specifically
on the language, because one of the thing
that I have to say is that
for the language part,
I communicate with the Hmong people
through either Thai language
because of the already, as I mentioned,
integrated in Thailand to a large degree.
So the way that they express themselves
or talk to me, right?
Always in the Thai language itself,
but behind the scenes whether
or not how they reconcile it
with the devil language
and devil cultures,
I cannot mention more
specifically on that.
And also into the last part
are the questions of power.
The question of power is
in terms of more of powers
and so on and so forth that
I already mentioned also.
I haven't thought about that much yet.
So perhaps that's the reason
why I haven't included in
these presentations for today.
So I cannot comment more specifically
on that part also for the time being.
But then that would let
me think more about it
because that was one idea that came out
from the notions of moral power
that even though like when it comes
to the policy of managing
refugees in Thailand,
that would be some form
of the moral powers
that kind of being used,
in order to actually allow these people
to stay in the countries.
And that got mentioned
several times already to me,
but nevertheless, I
haven't never get a chance
to really delve into details of those.
So I cannot comment more
specifically on that, sorry.
- [Teresa] I would be
interested in asking you
to pick up on the last
point that you mentioned,
I guess it was the second to
last about intersectionality
and the different
identities of these groups,
both in relation to before
when we met earlier,
we talked briefly about these
groups span Somali refugees,
refugees from Pakistan,
and then refugees from
neighboring countries.
So the kind of experience
of moving through the city
for those different groups
must be very different.
But also maybe you could
speak a bit on gender.
Are there anything else that
feels significant to you
in terms of what impacts
the way that people wield this power
that you've identified differently?
- I think that it's really important
to mention intersectionality.
I didn't bring it in into
my discussions here at first
because it's not related
directly to the powers.
But then of course, I
mean this urban power
is not shared equally among
different groups of people.
So different groups of
people draw different,
I mean the capacity they can
draw from these urban powers
is kind of diverse and
different, depend on groups.
For example, with regards
to the Somali, right?
As as you mentioned,
Somalis always get spotted
within the Thai societies
partially because they look different
in comparing to like Hmong
people or some other groups
that are from neighboring
countries, right?
So the (indistinct) for them
to actually integrate it
into the Thai societies is limited
comparing to other groups.
And then whenever they gathered
together in certain groups,
in certain areas, they
always get spotlight.
And then that's how the
arrest and detentions
of these groups have become
something that got more commons.
And then in many cases,
I mean many incidents,
of the arrest and detentions occur
with the groups of Africans refugees.
It occurred through the fact
that because of the Thai
immigration bureaus try
to label some operations
that focus specifically on
smuggling and so on and so forth,
of these groups of people into Thailand.
And because of this,
what happened is that they
become victims of that
you know, like arrests and
detentions and so on also.
So in terms of the intersections
of being, you know,
and then that's just on
ethnic ethnicities partly.
But now, another thing
that's more important though,
is that if we think about gender and race
also together, right?
What become clear to me also is that,
it also matters in the way
that how they got treated
and so on and so forth.
That for example, in the case of Thailand,
even though the arrests mostly occur
when it comes to the male refugees,
when it comes to female refugees, right?
The chance or livelihoods of
getting arrested, it's less.
And when it comes to
other groups, LGBTQI plus,
their livelihoods in Thailand
is also very difficult.
Particularly, if they live together
with people from their own community, why?
Because most of these people you know,
they have imported the
same social structure
from their own countries, right?
One of the Somali refugees who are LGBTQI
that I met for example, got
expelled from the community
and also experienced violence
within Thailand as well.
But then he cannot access to justice.
So the only way out for him
to escape from the community
and go and stay somewhere
else for example, right?
So in that case, these multiple
identities of the people
also have an impact
on how they're gonna be able
to survive within the cities.
And even though they already survive,
it doesn't mean that
that's gonna be the case
in the upcoming years
and so on and so forth.
So I think to think more
about intersectionality
in the context of livelihoods,
I think it's important.
And then I think that I haven't
done that well enough here
in these presentations today,
because I think that different groups
really draw on the powers differently.
So at the end of the day, the
degree to refugee resilience,
which is these different capacities,
also varies in degree as well, yeah.
- [Teresa] Questions.
So I think if you join me
in thanking professor Kaan
Jittiang for visiting us
and it's a pleasure to
have you here in person.
- Thank you so much.
And thank you so much for having me here.